[Music]
you got all this green all this point
all this red
I mean the vegetables in you have really
dry oh cool Mama's bursting talking we
have a decision to make
we either throw the woman on the bus or
we freakin protecting them and they gave
us life I mean really okay can you tell
me who this belongs to
[Music]
hold on the last few weeks I've been
lying to King about stealing my dime
let's talk about the emergency workout
let's get it going you know so in other
words you're sticking to your diet yeah
okay I really been stressed out and
eating since I had that meeting with
Jennifer I just left it made a few
hiding spots here and there what do we
have it is the girls is I haven't said
in there in a couple days wait wait wait
what's wrong you know yeah does this
male progress to you I've been working
out really hard yeah but you sabotaging
it with this and why are you laughing
this is no laughing matter I'm like you
know what no I'm back on the program if
you don't care I don't care I don't care
either I'm eating healthy now you've
come so far you can't keep messing up
like this exactly we're sitting over
here being supportive but you should
have a here line straight to our faces I
can't be more invested in this thing
than you because again this is your life
it's not what I found that disappoints
me it just seems like she doesn't care
and I can't deal with somebody who
doesn't care
[Music]